jo leute noch ein kleines update bevor
es wieder losgeht also wirklich an alle
vollmann die mädchen nehmen das wenig
mit humor wir wollen hier wirklich
niemand schlecht dastehen oder so das
kann vielleicht zurückkommen habe ich
mir auch gedacht es ist vielleicht ein
bisschen an der grenze aber bleibt auf
jeden fall bis zum schluss dran bevor
kommentiert wo habe ich schlecht stellt
die mädchen da oder so wir waren halt
alles jungs werden wir alles mädchen
wollen wir das gleich umgekehrt über
jungs machen aber wir sind halt jungs
warum macht man das halt so rum aber
über jungs gibt es das auch noch
irgendwie deswegen schild wir stellen
uns selber natürlich auch scheiße da bzw
parodieren das ist es ja überhaupt nicht
ernst gemeint deswegen ich hoffe ihr
versteht das und viel spaß mit dem video
das sollte aber auch eigentlich okay
sein also es gibt schönere content auf
youtube deswegen würde ich sagen der sco
meine hand fällt viel spaß
wir kommen direkt zum punkt wir haben
uns heute etwas ganz besonderes überlegt
ist es wirklich heftig dass spektakulär
ist das ist etwas das gab es noch nie
auf jedes ja also bei mir gab es schon
mal aber ich bin der von der china
wechsel jungs mädchen themen aber heute
haben wir das natürlich wieder
aufgegriffen und zwar was haben wir
drehen
so klärt man jedes mädchen im sommer
übrigens ich hab heute miguel capo dabei
und noch emil und mirko wollte wohl ganz
lange lahm gelegt an mit der ersten
option und 22
hey es geht
hast du lust auf ein date ich habe einen
freund bist du sicher
aber weißt du was nein ich habe 372.000
abonnenten auf youtube das zweite wohl
und jungs auch überzeugen können wenn
sie mädchen klären ist ganz klar
chillige klamotten leute kommt man also
the machine lady musstest du ja ich
dachte man könnte mal was starten oder
so ich habe zwölf runden
aber was wenn ich mal kurz im mp beute
jetzt erhältlich vielleicht kommen wir
zu option nummer drei und was ist das
das ist sie könnte auch mit anderen
mädchen überzeugen mit anderen sehr
großen bitte hey hast du nicht lust auf
ein date ja gern aber ich habe fünf
freunde
ja ich glaube das macht doch nichts oder
das ist das schöne ist wir haben
natürlich beide die heftigsten muskeln
das wissen wir und mit diesen reizen
habe ich so bis jetzt eigentlich fast
jede geklärt oder schon gut oder
seien wir ehrlich oder leute wie auch
überzeugen könnt ist wenn ihr den ganzen
quatsch einfach sein lassen und einfach
fragt ob sie bock hat oder so wie ich
eigentlich immer hat immer geklappt bis
jetzt seht selbst
ein
na super
ja
viele leute das war's mit diesem video
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lass
genau jetzt noch nach oben
was haben wir gesagt bei wie vielleicht
gibt es auch noch 50.000 battlestar
keine aber seien wir doch fast 20 grad
20 km bei 20.000 like strain gefühl noch
mal einen teil wie man jungs klärt was
wir auch nicht mehr auf jeden fall
checkt das video von mir egal ob das
dann zusammen mit ich das video von emi
und von mirko alles in der video
beschreibung schaut alles an abonniert
leicht alles zu tode damit wir youtube
übernehmen wurden damit um legenden
werden nicht folgen